son muchos en méxico los que piden la
renuncia del presidente andrés manuel
lópez obrador integrantes del frente
nacional anti hambre como se denomina el
movimiento que convocó la marcha
salieron a las calles de la capital para
manifestar contra el gobierno del
izquierdista a quien acusan de destrozar
el país
la verdad mucha gente creo que votó por
él por un cambio pero esto es demasiado
nos está llevando a la quiebra a todo el
país estamos demasiados
demasiada gente que ha perdido su empleo
y nada más no sé de forma de que esta
cosa va a interesar es por eso que
estamos este unidos aquí en este
movimiento porque no estamos de acuerdo
con este nuevo régimen no nos quieran
implementar definitivamente yo no quiero
eso para mi hijo yo quiero méxico libre
como el que yo tuve entonces yo quiero
tenemos de las mismas oportunidades lo
que nos sometan los manifestantes
convocaron a un paro económico nacional
para no pagar impuestos y así el
gobierno federal no puede recaudar
dinero los críticos del mandatario lo
acusan además de una mala gestión de la
pandemia de ccoo el 19 pero él lópez
obrador defiende la estrategia de su
gobierno aún cuando el país superó las
100.000 muertes y el millón de contagios
el mandatario rechaza la idea de
realizar toques de queda confinamientos
forzosos o incluso el uso obligatorio de
mascarillas al aire libre la pandemia
alimentó una crisis que ya se sentía en
el país la tasa de crecimiento anual es
de apenas el 2% del pib y su economía se
encuentra en la crisis más profunda
desde la gran depresión de la década
230 el banco central de méjico advirtió
que podría contraerse un 13% este año
los analistas aseguran además que la
recesión y el cierre de empresas
afectará a aquellos que se jubilen en el
futuro cercano